hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master Conrad whole darn knock
let's see what you can do against the
Zurich variation my main line from the
book should be true I think if I it was
my move
yeah it's a very strong blitz player and
of course a strong grandmaster in
general too and usually roughly elected
to 582 2600 kind of play it's very high
rated TN it's also and he usually kills
me completely it's the first game i have
with the chairs explained account
against them which is very surprising i
have played him a lot over the years and
i think i've scored nothing i mean
literally nothing again its position is
quite okay though for me these trades
are helpful only to show you one night a
form right h 52 f 4 also was on but this
is a position where queenside players
normally quite good
playing for before here threatening now
before I think it's a threat
yeah my rating is kind of rectum the
last live show was quite costly and yeah
I also played an absolutely atrocious
warm-up game and warm up is a funny word
because it's so hot I am currently in
Germany that you really are yea rather
thing of I know going for a swim or
something instead of playing playing
chess games but anyway what is that
Knight takes e4 it what is the big deal
i don't get it takes takes you can take
85 but this is also good for black of
course this one ok this one I didn't see
93 mmm smell a bad ending can also check
here Queen takes though ok our other
night moves are the other night moves ok
let's go 93
can bring the check oops oh yeah yeah
and just like that from some of a bad
position he's coming to a decent
position at least a decent position
maybe it's it's yeah I don't know what
it is but he's not worse that's for sure
I came maybe I'm worse after Quincy aid
in the ending when it shouldn't check
and too serious yeah this is hanging so
i have to go g6
socha ki roti 10 k 5 not sure what's
best
just bring the King up
yeah completely unnecessary to have that
kind of ending I was just quite a bit
better I have to move 20 but I didn't
seem 65 then we also don't understand
but we'll see what happens
thoughts this should just be a pretty
clean draw
I who first was better I think okay OOP
t3 I mean
check
ok create
hmm
yeah I don't have a clear way to trap
the rook which would be cute
would be really nice if I could trap it
but I don't think it works okay let's do
this I think it should be a draw either
way
you just seem absolutely no way forward
for white
I just go look at age five next pretty
much no matter what he does
check time warning I have six set a
problem it's unnecessary I had you to go
down but it should be a problem check
check I'm going to draw of course yeah I
bet that'll play this stuff on on the
win on time this is useless ja ja we can
play to the head to this daylight
Stanley yeah chair chair chair chair it
was spoiled opportunity I think because
in this position I'm just I'm just
substantially better but I did that
didn't didn't play it correctly I think
the computer wants to play it with night
h5 and this was an idea also before I
played be five but especially after you
went h3 this makes lots of sense as the
night is just better on a form the
computer wants to play like this by the
way very aggressive approach this is
indeed very nice yeah but it also says
I'm better here with f5 oh that
that move didn't occur to me at all it
makes a hit make some sense a I'm
winning this bond but nope see it yeah
yeah and here I'm certainly in some
danger check I mean I didn't think it
should be very bad but I was still
surprised that he played this I thought
this is a draw immediately after Roxy
fire basically because the dew point is
just harmed as I thought check and I
don't think I need to do this but I
think it's pretty clean yeah I can just
stay maybe I could have just something
out but I think it's a try ya hear that
was interesting still I shall take it
maybe this is this is that this looks
tricky okay the engine says it's a row
anyway but hey this is better check yeah
he gave me that point there is no chance
I simply cannot win look at that F 407
ok at least I got him go to draw against
on Hawkeye usually lose against him
every game so that's really good thanks
for watching